- I just discovered Face Dance,
which is like an app game.
It's like DDR for you face.
And I think it's the funniest
shit I have ever seen.
So I'm about to go around the office
and make all of my
coworkers look ridiculous.
(electronic music)
- (laughing) I just feel
like I'm spazzing out.
- Am I copying this one?
- [Man] You're copying the
emojis that are floating by.
- Crazy time.
- How, this is so--
(laughing) I give up on this.
(laughing)
- This is getting tiring. (laughing)
- Oh god, is it ever over?
- (laughing) This hurts my face!
(laughing)
- That's fuckin' hard.
- It is.
- I'm overstimulated, I can't do it.
That is what it feels like to
watch seven toddlers at once,
and there's just too much going on.
- I think it's a good bathroom game,
if I'm on the toilet.
In public, it's a little more awkward.
- It was an interesting experience,
but it's strangely fun.
I would never play this in public though.
- I got 900 points.
The fact that I got the lowest points,
I mean I believe it, it's
fine, it's fine. (laughing)
- 1870.
- [Woman] That's terrible.
(laughing)
- [Woman] Quinta, you
got the highest score
out of everyone.
- Yeah, winnin' is a habit. (laughing)
(electronic music)